bosses should be the ultimate test and
culmination of everything you've learned
throughout your time playing any given
video game at their best they're
exciting and test every ounce of skill
you have and at their worst
they're either boring or use unfair
mechanics
for this list i want to specifically
talk about difficulty which doesn't mean
unfair you might actually really enjoy
fighting some of these bosses
whereas others you can just be proud you
beat
so here is my
totally not subjective list of the 11
hardest bosses in video games
now as a warning there will be spoilers
because some of these are final bosses
for this kind of list you just can't get
around it but you can check the
description so you can skip around and
make sure you don't spoil a game you
don't want to spoil it for yourself so
let's get good
[Applause]
every kid growing up in the late 80s and
early 90s knew what that sound meant it
was time to strap on your gloves and get
ready to fight the dynamite kid
punch out or as it was originally called
mike tyson's punch out was nes gaming at
its finest the gameplay was simple but
both addictive and fun all you had to do
was memorize your opponent's patterns
and use those patterns to quickly
identify what they would do and strike
back of course like any good game the
challenge ramps up the further you
progress
and the final challenge was of course
mike tyson himself iron mic had
exceedingly quick strikes with only the
faintest amount of a tell it tested your
reflexes to their height and while
simple it was still so challenging that
beating him became a massive bragging
point
if there's one modern day company known
for fair and difficult yet rewarding
challenges it's from software and from
software's latest major game securo
not sekiro quick japanese lesson when
you've seen r japanese it actually
doesn't sound like an english r they
actually don't have that sound in
japanese it sounds like a mix between an
r and an l sound which is also why
native japanese speakers can have
trouble speaking english when it comes
to r's and l's they just don't have
those sounds in that language is another
incredible and compelling action game by
honestly one of my favorite developers
of all time
i'm still waiting for another one of
these bad boys
can we just pause the video for a moment
to talk about how great king's field is
and how badly it needs a revival
if no one else does it
i'm doing it so it's no surprise that
the final boss of sekiro would be one of
the most challenging video game bosses
period and that boss is ishin ashina now
i think there's a debate over if true al
is more difficult or ish in the sword
saints but as this is completely
subjective personally true al didn't
really give me that much trouble but ish
and the sword saints on the other hand
that is a whole other story the thing
about ishin ashina is it's essentially a
boss fight with not one
not two
not even three but four phases with the
first part of the boss fight being
against genitiro ashina which i'm
counting because if you lose against any
phase of this fight you have to start
right back at kinichiro
six hours
it took me six hours to beat ishan the
first time on subsequent playthroughs i
could knock him out in two to three
attempts but i'll never forget just how
insanely challenging ishin ashina was
before i truly mastered the game and as
much as i'm not a fan of excessively
multiple phase boss fights which i
consider this one it really is well
designed in that when i had truly
mastered securo he surprisingly was a
fun and fair boss fight
but again he truly is a test of
everything you've learned in the game
and unless you've at least approached
mastering it he is going to give you one
hell of a time
ishinashina i understand how you
succeeded in your war
we haven't finished the from software
part of this video
partly because i'm such a huge fan of
the company i'm intimately familiar with
just about every modern game of theirs
and partly because bloodborne is in many
ways more challenging than the souls
games thanks to his ramped up speed that
and the amazing world building are just
a couple of the elements that helped
bloodborne stand out from the souls
games and if you know from software you
know that their dlc happens to contain
the largest challenges of their games in
dark souls 1 that was manus in dark
souls 2 that was arguably fume knight
actually i take that back smelter demon
is still the worst
and in dark souls 3 that honor probably
goes to either freida or a slave night
gale then again dark eater madeira
honestly gave me more trouble than he
should have
but you know what was more challenging
than all of those bosses
again for me because this is just my
experience
bloodborne's orphan of cause while it
didn't take me six hours like ishin
oshina orphan is so hard to read he's
quick his attacks and attack patterns
vary broadly with different ways to
tackle them and of course as became
customary with the latter souls games
halfway through the fight orphan of
cause becomes far more challenging just
when you think you have the upper hand
he's sure to smash your face in with a
placenta
what a way to go
to many of you i'm sure when you think
of ninja gaiden you think of the
excellent ninja gaiden of 2004 it's a
crushingly difficult game which is why
it was perfect when team ninja merged
this action combo style with the soul
style to create neo and neo2
so i wouldn't fault you for thinking a
boss from this game deserves to be on
the list
but i'm not talking about that one
i'm talking about the original ninja
gaiden like the xbox ninja gaiden the
original nes game is a brutally
difficult challenge that's only made
easier thanks to infinite continues but
if you do lose all of your continues
you'll have to start at the beginning of
the stage now here is where the fun part
comes in lose the most bosses and so
long as you have lives left you'll get
to attempt fighting them again until you
get a game over and need to use a
continue lose to the game's final boss
jackie o and no matter how many lives
you have you're transported back to the
start of his level which is brutally
difficult in its own right in fact it's
so hard and frustrating it actually
inspired me to make an entire video
series joking about it because it is
just that insane and frustrating of an
experience
and if that's not hard enough alone
that's not really the boss fight itself
so thanks to my wii u and save states i
was finally able to do as many attempts
as i wanted against jokio without fear
of the horrible repercussions only to
discover
this boss is incredibly difficult even
being able to fight him as many times as
you want unless you collect a very
specific power up on the way into the
boss fight good luck because hitting him
without it is ridiculously hard on top
of that he'll constantly shoot homing
fireballs at you that continuously chase
you but hey if you beat him you'll get
the satisfaction of finding out there's
yet another boss fight right afterwards
don't lose or it's back to the beginning
of the stage again
so fun
so fun
this time i am being sarcastic
bullet hell is definitely one of the
most challenging genres of games the
whole point is being able to quickly
react and dodge into the most minuscule
of spaces it tests your hand-eye
coordination to the max and while i'm
going to get to one or two dedicated
bullet hell games i thought it would be
fun to start with something different
and a little more well-known
that being undertale undertale of course
isn't the hardest game and has multiple
ways to finish it without needing to
have a huge skill cap
but choose to be an [ __ ] and murder
absolutely everybody
yeah you're in for a bad time
sans will block your path to victory
trying to protect the undertale world
and this regular joker puts up one hell
of a fight he's essentially able to
break the rules of the game as he also
breaks the fourth wall meaning he can
even attack you while you're in the item
menu attempting to find something to
help you heal his attacks are an
onslaught of bullet hell and while the
game does prep you for this as its
combat is bullet hell in style this is a
glimpse into the madness of some of the
most insane shmup games
hollow knight is in my humble opinion
one of the best games to come out in the
past decade
this little indie darling is a perfect
encapsulation of action-oriented
metroidvania and as the game has a heavy
focus on action that means that the
bosses ramp up in difficulty to an
extreme
degree
i fondly remember being the nightmare
version of troop master grimm the
nightmare king and thinking
i did it the hardest challenge hollow
knight has to offer
complete
oh how innocent and naive i was
turns out hollow knight took a cue from
the souls games and made every dlc
progressively more challenging
one could even say hollow knight is the
dark souls of metroidvania i'm kidding
now that i work here i hope you
understand i'm just spoofing on that
meme while the grim troop was a hollow
knight dlc the final one godmaster
is just absolutely bonkers difficult so
here's the thing this dlc includes some
of the most difficult boss fights in the
game
but wrapped up as part of a boss rush
pantheon meaning you'll have to complete
insanely challenging boss rushes to even
be able to attempt many of these new
bosses
you'll have to become the absolute king
and master of hollow knight in order to
finish the godmaster dlc and i'm going
to be honest with you all the godmaster
dlc took me out and as much as i
absolutely adore the game i haven't
finished this particular dlc so the rest
of it's going to be word of mouth but if
the lesser bosses of the godmaster dlc
gave me as much trouble as they did then
i can only imagine that the final boss
of the dlc is the peak of insane
difficulty i'm talking about absolute
radiance lore wise absolute radiance is
the infection that has caused the
hallowness citizens to turn into
zombie-like beings and now
you're fighting her and she is brutal
she's basically a beefed up version of
the original final boss radiance but
like any alternate version of a boss in
hollow knight far
far more difficult
and don't you worry every phase of her
boss fight she gets progressively more
challenging so you'll never really get
that sigh of relief you desperately want
until you become the utmost master of
the game this fight requires
memorization reflexes and patience as
one false step could spell the end
enter the gungeon is kind of an
interesting one because
well
the difficulty really depends on your
rng and what items you happen to get as
this is a roguelike and even getting to
these various bosses can be based on a
mix of skill what items and guns you're
fortunate enough to get and of course
the bosses themselves are randomized
additionally i think depending on what
you happen to be good at some will be
easier than others while it's been a
while since i delved into the gungeon
for me the dragon is pretty basic when
you get its pattern down and i honestly
didn't struggle too much against the
lich but that damn rat let's throw
everything aside about how difficult it
is to even find the resourceful rat in
the first place as that doesn't really
count even though it's convoluted and
hard and
actually pretty cool the resourceful rat
has three phases the first phase
involves him shooting a variety of quick
attacks at you with typically small
spots to dodge as is typical for a
bullet hella game if you survive that
he'll hop in a mech with another set of
brutal attacks
all of this is hard enough and is
compounded by the fact that since
choosing to fight him is early in the
game you're less likely to be op against
him
but then
it's punch out
in this final phase you'll have a two
minute time limit to knock out the rat
three times
the further you get the more items you
get for winning and if you fail
technically you've still won but not 100
percent and to be honest with you all i
don't think i've ever 100 of the rat i
had to look up a video just to see what
happens when you manage to do it so well
done index 154 and don't worry i've
played hades i just happen to think
enter the gungeon is more challenging
especially since the shield is super op
in my opinion
most of the time when you think about
difficult bosses you probably think
about skill based challenges
you know things that require fast
reflexes combo memorization or pattern
recognition it's not too often you think
about jrpgs but i thought it would be
fun to throw one in here so let's talk
about final fantasy vii
still one of the greatest jrpgs of all
time and even the recent remake was
incredible it's so good one of the
things i absolutely adored about final
fantasy 7 was just how much you could do
that wasn't strictly story related
raising and racing various chocobos so
you could get the gold chocobo was so
much fun
everything about gold saucer especially
the snowboard mini game i love and then
the hidden summons like knights of the
round which literally takes over one
minute to watch and isn't skippable by
the way
incredible but what that also means was
that there were some insanely epic
bosses in ff7 in the form of the weapons
who were far
far more difficult than sephiroth in
particular i'm talking about the emerald
and ruby weapons and yes that's
technically two bosses and i'm cheating
but
uh okay yeah i'm i'm cheating i'm naming
these two in particular because i
haven't beaten them that's just what i
get for losing my memory card in my
elementary school playground on a snowy
day
all of my main characters were level 90.
it was devastating but that also tells
you something my characters were
incredibly overpowered and i still
hadn't beaten them now looking back
there are some cool strategies i didn't
think of because i was 10 years old but
that's kind of the point with these guys
being overpowered didn't do it you had
to use creative strategies to defeat
them creative strategies that i was too
stupid to think of when i was 10
or before i lost my memory card
i'll never forget it i also had this
amazing final fantasy tactic save going
on that i also lost
it was it was the worst
the nes was known for two things for one
being full of some amazing games i could
talk about the blue bomber all day and
for two
they're hard
i already listed ninja gaiden and punch
out for being challenging nes games but
there's another series that definitely
deserves a shout
castlevania castlevania is absolutely
brutal in part thanks to its fixed jump
you see in this game when you choose to
jump just like in real life you're going
that direction there's no changing it so
you better be damn sure you intend to go
where you want when you hit that button
on top of that the bosses hurt you for a
great deal of health so you know there's
that too and of course dracula the final
boss of the game has two forms so right
away ridiculously hard but you know
what's harder than that castlevania
three where dracula now has three forms
and if you die you have to start right
back at form number one it is brutal and
i do not know how people accomplish this
without save states but i'm very
impressed that is quite the achievement
oh look a game about a cute penguin what
could possibly go wrong you start with 1
000 lives and
oh
right you start the game with 1000 lives
because the challenge of the game is
beating it without losing all 1 000 of
those lives so you can imagine that when
i tell you that a game with this premise
has some super hard bosses
it probably has some super hard bosses
and the final boss in his second and
final form sir sweet is a calamity
there's only so many times i can say
ridiculous insane or brutal
i'm running out of synonyms he's tough
to hit the main mechanic of the game
stunning bosses to hurt them doesn't
work on him and you'll basically be
required to memorize every single aspect
of this boss fight without messing up
once in the three minute time limit in
order to actually beat him it is stupid
it is ridiculous and that is why it's on
this list
so this one is kind of a bonus entry
because as much as i enjoy shoot em ups
bullet hells in games like ikaruga this
one is more so just widely notorious and
a game that i haven't played and that is
the final boss of mushihimesama futari i
honestly don't think there's too much to
say about this one
i'm just gonna show you footage
[Music]
my list is limited to games i've played
or games that are notorious so i'm
asking you are there any bosses i should
have listed i almost put sigma from mega
man x the final boss of illusion of gaia
and sephiroth of kingdom hearts but they
just didn't quite make my cut let me
know what you think and if you'd like to
see a similar video about difficult
levels or unfair bosses and i'll see you
guys next time
peace
you